does Russia intercept store were
analyzed in any way the communications
of millions of individuals we bootleg
Yente you are a former agent I also was
part of the same services so we can talk
as professionals we have very strict
rules and regulations about the use of
special equipment and methods by the
secret services including listening into
telephone conversations intercepting
Internet communications it requires a
court's permission that for us to
monitor individual citizens so there is
no mass monitoring and the law would not
permit it
of course our view is that modern
communications are being used by various
criminal forces including terrorists for
their criminal activities and of course
the secret services are therefore forced
in that sphere to use what equipment
they have to respond and to fight
terrorism we do that but on a mass scale
uncontrolled mass scale of course we do
not permit ourselves to do that and I
hope I very much hope that we will never
allow ourselves to do that we don't have
the money for it like the United States
does